le talon attribut féminin par excellence
mais saviez vous qu'il peut se conjuguer
au masculin exemple dans les années 50
pour vous maintenant petit monsieur
voici lift antilopes noires spécialement
étudié pour grandir les hommes de 8 cm
alors oui à l'époque les talons pour
hommes sont un accessoire qui permet de
se grandir et qu'il est d'ailleurs de
bon ton de dissimuler pantalon assez
long pour cacher le talon est recommandé
talons talonnettes pour gagner quelques
centimètres de virilité même combat dans
les années 70 alors que les femmes se
mettent à la chaussure plate forme avec
des talons de huit voire douze
centimètres
les hommes ne sont pas en reste alors ça
ce n'est pas une sculpture abstraite
c'est une chaussure une chaussures pour
hommes une véritable show sur les
chaussures à la mode de cette année que
les courageux les élégants et les
sportifs peuvent acquérir chez tous les
chausseurs désireux de ne pas rater le
dernier train de la mode
le bus être à la mode bien sûr mais
aussi garder une certaine stature selon
ce cordonnier catalan pour la femme la
jolie pour les hommes et pour les hommes
automatique morte qu'elle est un homme
et la bge oise des champions toujours un
peu plus grand quine femmes
automatiquement il a adopté il est très
content d'avoir des chaussures à talons
go même si les santiags et les bottines
seront à la mode pour les hommes dans
les années 70 les normes chaussures
plates formes fera un flop
une bonne nouvelle pour ce médecin je
suis un peu surpris par la chaussure
d'hommes que vous me montrez ça
ressemble terriblement une chaussure
orthopédique commandant donne de les
hôpitaux pour les gens qui ont un
raccourcissement d'un an
mais le talon haut pour homme n'est pas
pour autant enterrée dès la fin des
années 80 jean paul gaultier bouscule
les codes féminins masculins les talons
ne sont pas là pour rendre l'homme plus
grand que la femme
mais pour qu'il assume sa part de
féminité
et dans les années 2000 certains
journalistes se demandait même si cette
mode d'aller pas finir par prendre
ils jouent une fois encore les mauvais
élèves en faisant défiler des hommes en
allant au four provocateur pour certains
visionnaires pour d'autres et si jean
paul goutines n'était autre que le
révélateur de nouvelles tendances de
notre société
alors pour l'instant le talon aiguille
pour rami 100% assumer n'est pas encore
tendance
en revanche certains hommes adorent les
chaussées mais c'est plus pour courir
avec ses bras je le trouve à l'aise avec
des talons au fait et puis ça vient
mettre des jupes donc ça on est allé
aussi
[Musique]